today the team is colouring an elephant
with a state-of-the-art device that
might save its life a tag that sends an
alert when the animal nears a farm you
may any elephants across Africa get shot
because they cause damage to human
property to crops to livelihoods and
indeed they kill people
Iain douglas-hamilton searches for a
herd scanning the landscape by air while
researcher David double ons team is on
the ground
sorry in where I'm setting the two
groups of elephants tightly under the
tree has found them in a perfect place
we don't want to lose them because you
know they're not quite often at the
moment are so we want to take that
opportunity to add them put a collar
because we will know them from our past
experience they will defend so much and
if we have forecast we can position
ourselves in different positions to make
sure that the females would not see the
female that has gone down
they identify the female to be collared
that
she's down good position right
once she's unconscious double on has
only 20 minutes to attach the collar the
anesthesia makes the trunk muscles go
slack a stick will keep her airway open
this particular collar will do what
Douglas Hamilton once only dreamed of it
will allow an elephant to communicate
with him the collar sends its alert to a
cell phone via text message
this high-tech innovation is called
geofencing
when an elephant crosses a virtual fence
line the GPS unit in the collar sends an
SMS or text message to a server in
Nairobi the server then sends text
alerts to a list of recipients who can
quickly intercept the herd before it
reaches a farm or human settlement